bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors l'accord de libre
échange entre l'europe et le vietnam est
effectif à partir d'aujourd'hui
en quoi va-t-il consistait précisément
ça a été dit dans le petit sujet que
vous avez chez à l'instant c'est à dire
que c'est un accord de libre échange
c'est un accord de libre échange qui
vise à réduire considérablement les
droits de douane et à intensifier le
commerce entre l'union européenne et et
le vietnam avec les mécanismes habituels
qui sont désormais prévues dans les
accords de libre échange que signent
très régulièrement l'union l'union
européenne et ça a été dit également
dans votre petit sujet c'est un accord
de libre échange qui est présenté par la
commission comme une réponse à la crise
économique que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et comme d'habitude la
commission donne comme réponse une
réponse néolibérale c'est à dire un
renforcement du libre échange
y compris si ça ne garantit pas la
protection d'environnement et si non
plus ça ne garantit pas les droits les
droits sociaux on va rappeler ce chiffre
le vietnam qui est le deuxième plus
grand partenaire commercial de l'union
européenne en asie avec plus de 47
milliards d'euros d' échanges de
marchandises
on parle de la vente et de l'achat de
quel type de marchandises entre le
vietnam et l'union européenne alors
essentiellement le vietnam entend
s'insérer dans le commerce international
avec ce qu'on appelle des marchandises à
faible valeur ajoutée c'est-à-dire que
il n'est pas il ne se positionne pas sur
les marchandises de haute valeur ajoutée
mais sur toutes les marchandises qui
aujourd'hui alors notamment entre autres
le textile qui sont fabriqués dans des
conditions sociales désastreuses souvent
et aussi les marchandises qui sont
polluantes va je veux dire dans la
fabrication est polluante et ce qui
permet à l'union européenne de faire en
sorte que la consommation qu'elle a de
produits polluants soient fabriqués par
d'autres pays et non pas par elle vous
voyez la manière dont l'union européenne
entend respecter l'accord de paris c'est
à dire en faisant supporter à d'autres
pays qui ne respectent pas les normes
environnementales la fabrication de
produits de produits paul lourd oui
alors on la dirait vous l'avez rappelé
cet accord est contestée par des ong en
raison de son coût écologique mais aussi
de la situation des droits humains dans
le pays le vietnam qui s'est pourtant
engagé à faire des efforts
supplémentaires sur le développement
durable et le droit du travail
je souris en entendant cela mais je ne
devrais pas sourire parce qu'en réalité
c'est tout à fait dramatique c'est à
dire que bien entendu le vietnam s'est
engagé il s'est engagé
d'autant plus que ça ne lui coûte rien
puisque comme d'habitude dans ce type
d'accord l'union européenne a inclus un
chapitre sur le développement durable a
inclus un chapitre sur les droits
sociaux sur l'environnement qui sont des
chapitres qui ne sont pas contraignants
et qui de toute façon ne donneront lieu
à aucun contrôle puisque on a affaire au
vietnam en dictature
bon alors c'est une dictature qui fait
moins de bruit que les autres parce que
elle est politiquement pas très éloigné
d'une des etats-unis de l'union
européenne mais c'est une dictature
et comme toute la dictature elle est
très proche des entreprises et des
grandes entreprises
elle est donc extrêmement corrompu et
bien entendu elle ne contrôlera
strictement jamais
les conditions dans lesquelles les
produits exportés seront fabriqués ni
sur le plan social ni sur le plan
environnemental
aujourd'hui on l'union européenne
conclut des accords avec un pays dans
lequel est bien quand on conteste
on va en prison quand on est un
syndicaliste on risque d'être tuée
lorsque l'on contrôle comme lorsqu'on se
bat pour l'environnement on risque on
risque l'emprisonnement ou l'assassinât
c'est ça la réalité alors on aura des
beaux rapports sur papier glacé qui vont
nous expliquer que oui tout va bien
la commission européenne de manière
extrêmement hypocrite va s'en contenter
et c'est tout elle le fait déjà pour le
mexique d'ailleurs un donc elle a
l'habitude de faire ça frédéric viale
vous êtes juriste et auteur de
manifestent contre les accords
transatlantique aux éditions eric monier
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
ici